Você sabia que a música certa pode ser o
remédio natural contra o enjoo no carro?
Olha só essa descoberta que saiu agora.
Pesquisadores chineses testaram 30
pessoas em simuladores de direção e
descobriram algo fascinante. Músicas
alegres e relaxantes conseguiram reduzir
náuseas e tonturas em até 14% durante as
viagens. Já as músicas tristes fizeram
exatamente o oposto, pioraram os
sintomas e ainda atrapalharam a
recuperação. Pois é, isso acontece
porque a música não afeta só o nosso
humor, ela também interfere diretamente
na resposta emocional do nosso cérebro e
na forma como processamos as informações
visuais. Então, quando estamos enjoados
no carro, nosso sistema vestibular do
ouvido interno já está em conflito com o
que nós vemos e a música certa ajuda o
cérebro a reorganizar essas informações
de forma mais harmoniosa. É como se a
trilha sonora desse uma mãozinha pro
nosso sistema nervoso se acalmar. Então,
na próxima viagem, experimente trocar
aquela playlist melancólica por algo
mais animado e também relaxante.